In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and take a look at Lightmass, baking, CPU and GPU.
So let's get started.
So CPU, Lightmass and GPU can be used for baking.
We're going to mainly focus here up front on CPU baking.
And both of those are kind of the old school way to be able to bake out your lighting in
a scene.
Now, Lumen will update on the fly because the lights are dynamic and Lumen is dynamic
and updates in real time.
But when it comes to CPU baking, particularly we and GPU, you have to actually go in here
and set up your lights accordingly, bake out your lights, and then you'll get the desired
look and feel for your scene.
Now it's very important.
There's several ways that are several things you need to keep in mind when working with
this.
And I will point these out.
You want to anticipate your needs for sure when it comes to working with your scene ahead
of time because baking will take some time, especially if your scene is large.
Now GPU baking, GPU Lightmass baking does beat up the process.
But again, you have to come in with a strategy and a game plan to be able to actually work
a little bit more efficient.
And say you have to bake on set, immediately you want to make sure that you know exactly
what you need and want, especially if changes are coming in pretty hot and heavy.
Now Lumen is a more ideal approach.
But again, I want to cover this because there may be some times when you're like, Lumen's
doing great, but we just can't seem to get rid of noise in this particular area.
And that's when you can lean upon your CPU and GPU baking.
So you always want to start low and then go high.
And you want to keep things at a medium level when it comes to static lighting level scale.
This details gives you details of your Lightmass.
Remember of indirect, your indirect lighting bounces, keep that low.
That's a brightness of your scene overall, basically your GI, kind of how that indirect
lighting is bouncing around.
Indirect lighting quality, try to keep that high if you can.
This decreases artifact noise and indirect lighting smoothness, keep this low.
This blurs indirect lighting component in your light map.
So again, keeping these things in mind as you work through your process.
Now if you're unfamiliar with the baking process, maybe you're new to Unreal and you're more
on the Lumen phase, let me point out where these things can be found.
So in my world settings, you'll see that we have a Lightmass settings area.
You'll see Lightmass as the topic.
And from there, we would open this up.
We see our static lighting level scale.
Our scene's pretty small, so we don't have to adjust this too much.
There are some darker shadow areas in here that we can clean it with some lights moving
nearby.
But some of this is caused because of the thickness that is not included in some of
these rocks.
And that can be a little bit tricky.
So the same rule that we came across when it came to Lumen, it's kind of the same process
here.
We want to make sure we have thick pieces of geo.
And you'll notice that I've extruded them in Unreal using the modeling tool.
There's a bit of banding.
And I'm not worried about the EVs on the other side.
It's this side where I'm more concerned.
Now if you don't do that, you can get these dark areas.
And let me show you a little bit up close.
So if I go in here and bring in a rec light, anytime you bring in a new light, Unreal's
going to give you a warning and say, buddy, you really do need to rebuild your lighting.
And the two modes for your lights you're going to be in a constant, going to be in a constant
positioning for is you want to make sure that you set things to either static, and that's
for objects that don't move, and stationary.
And that can be for objects that do move in your scene.
But again, both lights do not move.
The stationary one is a bit more complicated than the static.
The static is the cheapest.
Stationary is the second to that.
And movable is the most expensive since it's dynamic.
Stationary allows you to change the intensity of the light and the color and your characters
and moving objects to be affected by that light with the shadows updating.
So in this light here, we can bring this into our scene.
And then we would have to go in here and make it so this light is bouncing around in our
environment.
And you can see we can remove some of those dark areas simply by moving things around.
Now again, you can increase the strength of this light, and you can remove some of that.
And you can also control your width and height when it comes to your scene in here.
And as you do, the energy will kind of be removed from the object as you increase the
size, because it is again, like a series of point lights inside of a rectangle or square,
depending on what shape you choose.
And it is the most expensive light, but you'll see we're removing some of those dark
areas.
Some of them may still persist in some regions, but that's a quick way to be able to get that
up and running.
But again, you want to keep things low when you're working in your scene.
So that's one way you can fix it.
And you can even bump up the saturation in some areas if it's persistent to maybe cheat
some of that or even correct your texturing.
But overall, your light map density needs to be of the same level.
Well, what does that mean?
So if we go to lit here and we go to optimization view modes, we want to go to our light map
density here.
And you can see it in here showing us different resolution types.
And you'll notice for teaching purposes, I've actually kept this one a bit high.
This could be definitely a lot higher.
I should say a bit low.
This could definitely be a lot higher so that they have the same resolution between the
rocks.
So if I went in here, I would want to change this override and make it from a 62 or excuse
me, a 62, a 64 and make that a bit higher.
You'll see the other one here.
He's a 128.
So we kind of probably want a 128 here too.
And the reason why we do that is it can prevent some of those dark regions that could occur
and blobby areas working with your again, your world settings for your light mass.
So let's go back into the light mass here.
And I just want to give you some quick tips there for those dark regions that may occur.
Now again, indirect lighting quality, we have control here, keep these numbers low initially.
You can also control your overall color for your environment.
Now all of these changes that I've just made, including if I chose to maybe change the color
of everything, it's going to affect my final bake.
When you are baking, make sure that you set your builds to, if we go here to production.
Now we're in preview.
That means the build is going to be pretty quickly.
But if you want to see that actual bounce, we want to set that to production.
Let's go ahead and go back to the slides.
So you also want to take into account what kind of light you're using, like we mentioned
before, static versus stationary.
Now if you decide that you need a movable light is a move in your scene, you need to
make sure that mesh distance fields are active within your project settings.
Now again, you can use CPU light mass for final pixel, as well as ICVFX.
And you can also use GPU light mass if you need it.
So keep in mind that Lumen will probably be your best bet, especially if you want updates
on the fly.
So keep those things in mind when you're working with Unreal.
Now your volumetric clouds are expensive and will need adjustment for CPU baking for believability.
So they will not render accurately at this time with ray tracing.
So if you choose that, that is still on the roadmap.
So keep that in mind.
So never forget the power of the rec light.
That's one reason I showed it to you.
It can fill those areas that you need.
And that even goes for Lumen, as you saw me do earlier, that will fill that space and
give and fake some of the bounce light that we may or may not be getting immediately.
So again, you can control on the point lights your source length and your source radius,
as well as your overall view and feel and shape for that with those properties.
So let me actually jump into Unreal real quick.
So if you do get a hot spot or say this, this is not highly reflective, but if it was,
I could go in here and soften that up using my soft source radius.
And unfortunately, it can pixelate your shadow.
So just be aware of that.
I just want to mention that too.
Remember also too, when it comes to light mass, make sure you use area shadows for stationary
light.
So if this is a stationary light and I keep it like this, say I want to use it to maybe
fill out some bounce light in here, I would again turn that on and then I would make a
fresh build bake in this environment.
So here are some pro tips when it comes to using CPU baking.
Try to make sure your geo is solid.
Now this is a golden rule working with Unreal as well as Lumen.
Having hollowed out pieces of geometry can be tricky.
So when intersected, it makes sense to Unreal.
Now you will see some times where you might see that rule broken.
There's like a cafe that I use every once in a while.
There's a thin floor.
There's thin walls.
It's really made for baking.
And it works okay.
It's not too bad.
And there really isn't much light leaking.
But as soon as I switch to Lumen, that's where things might be a little weird in some areas
and some corners of it because the mesh distance field isn't quite calculated incorrectly, especially
if I step out of that area or I rotate in such a way that those little thin areas are
revealed in some way, the mesh distance field gets a bit confused.
You want to keep your light map resolution for intersecting geo, which I mentioned before,
the same or at least in the same ballpark.
This will prevent any blobby shadows on the seams, any weird light leaking that might be
happening.
Can't seem to say leaking before the leaking, leaking.
I don't know what's happening.
Or in tears, you can use light mass portals, but can be expensive.
So use them deterministically.
Now, light mass portals that you heard me mention earlier and other classes, light mass portals
do not work with GPU light mass.
They only work with CPU.
For some reason, do not calculate correctly.
And they're basically put in front of opening of a cave or a window versus interior and
an exterior.
You're right for that cusp in that area where the values change, and that's what you would
use it for.
Rec lights were great for interiors as fill lights, but can be expensive.
And again, they are point lights over that surface, like a series of point lights.
So indirect lighting quality can be increased, but can be expensive with build times.
Keep that in mind.
Default maybe fine and turn off compressed light maps.
So you can do that again, inside of your world settings for light mass, and you can turn
that compress off right there.
Make sure the stationary lights are set to use area shadows, like I mentioned before
also.
So don't forget that.
Outside of ICV effects, though, you can show to your director different lighting scenarios.
Now you can use that level snapshot, but if you have a lot of static lights, it doesn't
really work really cleanly.
You can cheat a little bit and use a thing called a streaming level node.
And we can use a level blueprint, but you can only show off three at a time.
So that's a bit of the limitation.
So this is again, why lumens a little bit better.
Let me show you a little bit of how that works in engine.
And you can get an idea of what I'm talking about.
So in Unreal, I'm going to go to our class folder.
I'm going to go to maps.
And I'm going to go into here and click on base.
Now it's going to ask you to save.
I'm really not saving anything.
I'm going to click on base here.
I'm going to say, don't save.
Now when I open up this base file, you're going to notice that there's really not much
to write home about.
It's pretty much just a dark environment.
So what I did, let me click on my drawer and click here, what I did was I created a level
blueprint in here.
So let's go and open this up.
Let's open up our level blueprint.
And in this level blueprint, I loaded other scenes that I already baked out the lights.
I created a thing called a multigate.
You can also use a sequence if you wanted to.
That one works just fine.
So that's up to you.
If you want to use that, you can see sequence here.
Kind of works about the same way.
I just basically use the multigate, which is used for weapon swapping.
So I built this guy in here.
I had a hotkey to start it out, created a level switch here, Boolean, put it into the loop,
and I used a current level here, which is an integer.
And I put it into the start index so it actually knows my intentions.
From there, I created a unload stream level and a load stream level.
I started out with one of my choice, which is like the day one that I baked out daylighting.
And I cycled it through.
There's a night one.
You load it.
You unload it.
It's really that easy.
Load it, unload it.
And then make sure that you compile once you get everything in there that you need.
I do want to point out, though, as you click on this, you want to make sure you have make
visible after load, make visible after load, and make visible after load for all of the
load streaming little nodes that we have here, little sets that we have.
So in my multigate, you notice it's pretty simple.
Level switch here.
You make sure you turn on level switch.
Click on that little node there.
And we have current level.
You'll notice that's just set by default, but we are using an integer setting that to
that.
And then now you got to make sure you get the names right.
That's really super important.
So once you get the names right, we can now go in here in our scene.
And if I hit play, now, again, this is why it's not really used for ICVFX because you
can't do this with a switchboard setup and so forth.
But if you're doing virtual production, this actually works pretty well.
I can hit play and click in the environment and hit X. And I can load, hey, there's my
kind of nighttime area.
Here's my super blue, not sure just the super blue day planet of blueness.
And then we have our daytime in here.
And I'm just cycling through and we can fly through the environment too.
And we can see a comparable of these different environment lighting scenarios.
So you only get three.
Now, I have a really powerful computer.
It's an A6000 threadripper.
And I am at my max limit GPU-wise, so I can't do a fourth.
So just keep that in mind.
Let's go back to the slides.
So if you're interested, I'll walk you through each one of these.
Again, I do recommend level snapshot using Lumen, but this is another one that you can
use.
If you were to use level snapshot, make sure that you have primarily stationary lights
in your environment.
Lighting between bakes can be a little bit clunky for static lighting, but stationary
light seems to work OK with level snapshot.
But mostly you want to use that for Lumen.
And again, each step is walking you through how these work.
That's it for this video.
In the next video, we're going to take a look at GPU light mass in detail and how that works.
Thanks again.
Thank you.